[Music]
this is
the ramsay show you can be intentional
about your character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice
doing this show now almost 30 years and
getting to um meet some of my heroes
along the way has been one of my great
joys and then occasionally
actually getting to become friends with
them and even more than that
getting to do some work with them from
time to time today is no exception for
that pastor louis giglio
of passion church in atlanta uh good
friend has stopped by with his new book
and we're so honored to have you with us
here my friend
i couldn't be happier to be here with
you congrats on the space it's
absolutely stunning well thank you thank
you you know what you know about spaces
with passion and the passion movement
and uh fabulous books over the years if
you've never heard pastor louis giglio
speak i don't know where you've been
he's one of the top communicators in the
world and uh
you if you're in the atlanta area always
or anywhere you can
catch him passion city church i've had
the privilege of speaking there
and just wonderful people wonderful
family of god good good folks and i
always like getting to hang out with him
especially when we get to talk about a
new book that he's doing called don't
give
the enemy a seat at your table that's
pretty straight on
it's really to the point it's one of
those books that you don't have to read
the whole book i do recommend that
people
read the book but i like the ones that
you get the message
on the cover total money makeover total
money makeover that's what i need to do
oh you're going to tell me how to do
that this is the message don't give the
enemy a seat at your table if this
enemy could come into paradise dave
think about it
paradise and lie his way in
to the hearts of mankind and say good
god isn't good
and you can't trust him if he can do
that in paradise
he can definitely do it in my life he
could do it in anybody's life he can do
it in atlanta
he can do it in nashville he can do he
can do it in dallas and houston
he can do it when things are unraveling
and it's not paradise
if he could do it in paradise so we got
to watch what we think we gotta
be careful what thought we allow to take
a seat at our table
you know this is apparently my week for
spiritual warfare
um books and information our pastor did
our devotional yesterday was from kansas
city
spoke on the subject of that and has
just written a book on it as well that
i've read half of it this morning before
i came to work and um
but but uh you know he was just making
the point
that that and you know this more than i
do but i also already knew it but it was
good to be reminded that
very seldom does the enemy uh come
straight
at you instead he brings you something
that's 98 percent truth
yeah i mean there's there's a very few
occasions where the enemy shows up and
says hey
i'm the enemy uh i would like to rip
your eyeballs out
yeah you know i want to destroy your
marriage i would like to
destroy your confidence i want to take
your business down
no he comes in that side door where
where i was
actually when i got this message i'd
been through about a four-month battle
and some things have been said some
things have been done about four months
in
i get a phone call and the phone call is
i bet you've got one like this you're
not going to believe what happened
today it was that moment of vindication
and i reached out to a friend and i and
i said you are not going to believe what
i just heard
if you give things enough time what did
i want dave i wanted commiseration
i want somebody just to come alongside
and say hey man you're good
and you were right but my friend knew i
didn't need commiseration
my friend that i sent the text to knew
that i needed a wake-up call because i
was acting like an
orphan when i'm the son of a king
and he sent me nine words in reply don't
give the enemy a seat at your table in
other words his whole four months of
consternation
frustration all this internal processing
you've been doing
all that is because you let the enemy
sit at your table and you need to take
your thinking back
starting today and that text became the
cover
of this book the title of this book and
that text has
literally changed my life over the last
six eight years
well when you get pounded and uh i have
been this year you have been this year a
lot of people have been this year by
different things
um uh but i mean i watched and
sent you positive texts during that time
as well and
uh uh you know i
we forget to do the basics like take
every thought captive and instead we sit
and it's almost like in the seventh
grade at the lunch table
you know when you walk away and you go
you know now i know what i should have
said
now and you just play these tapes over
and over and over and over and over
again
about how you're going to hit back or
how you're not going to hit back or how
you're going to do this
all that and all of that is just you're
playing right into this
yeah that's what i'm saying you know
it's we want to control
everyone if they really are honest wants
to control
and we don't control a lot like this
global craziness that we're living in
no one's in control of that so what are
we in control of we're in control of the
truth that god has given us for our
lives and
i think that you know when when we get
in a moment like that
what we normally do is just say okay
great fear
you're at the table worry you're at the
table anger you're at the table instead
of going wait a minute where did you
come from
and that's what this book talks about
asking the thought
where did you come from and if that
thought doesn't line up with the
character the purposes the heart and the
word of god
then it didn't come from god right and
if it didn't come from god it doesn't
get a seat
at the table and so you got to know the
truth
because you don't win this battle by
fighting against a lie you win this
battle by embracing
the truth you know that's convicting and
disgusting at the same time because i
did i just
i completely violated that and i'm not
like an immature person
i'm like an immature person spiritually
or emotionally anything else and i
completely violated that
i can look back in the last nine months
and go i did that there i did that there
i did that and i
know better well this is a good reminder
yeah we all know better and i think the
thing that
what i would want to encourage people in
and for me
is that you don't win the battle of your
mind one time you win the battle of your
mind every day that's what god's word
says
renew your mind every single day keep
renewing your mind to the truth and
it's not something that you do and then
walk away from because
our minds are an open field
to whatever seeds want to get blown
there by whatever wind
is coming our way and we've got to think
every single time
i've got the authority to take control
of my mind
and then that what people really need to
start with i can do this i can change
the way i think yeah i'm
i'm in charge of my thoughts no one else
is
it's one of the few things i actually
can control do not
don't give the enemy a seat at your
table it's for sale
anywhere great books are for sale pastor
louis giglio of passion city church
the original visionary of the entire
passion movement
is my guest this segment and this is a
book we all need as a reminder
because not only do you become who you
hang around with you become what you
think about
and uh both of those are scriptural
concepts and
uh and if you hang around with and think
about the enemy's
processes thoughts and presence you're
gonna get a lot out of him pastor love
you
love you too so good to see you
appreciate you coming by and hanging out
with us here in nashville
again the book don't give the enemy a
seat
at your table this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to puretalk
they use the same network as the larger
providers for much less
for just 30 a month get unlimited talk
text
and six gigs of data with no contract
the average family saves over 70 dollars
a month by switching
to pure top just go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save
50 off your first month pure talk
simply smarter wireless
[Music]
number one best-selling author ken
coleman ramsey personality is my co-host
today as we take your questions about
your life and your money here on the
ramsey show
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five triple eight eight two five
five
two two five well happy birthday ken
well thank you dave
i uh it's it's hard to believe
they sneak up on me every year i don't
know if yours do but mine do
kind of like i didn't see it coming i
got all the old man jokes
right so it's like uh the closer it's
like life's like toilet paper the closer
you get to the end the faster it goes
oh it's it's so good dave we got this
fun tradition i got to let people in on
this where dave sends out
everybody gets an email if you're a
ramsay solutions teammate you get an
email on your birthday
and there's always some fun uh gif or
whatever they call it jiff or gif i
never know what to say
and today was a picture of albert
einstein
saying that uh studies show that uh
birthdays are good things you know
something something along those lines
studies show that birthdays are good for
statistics shows the birthdays are good
for you the more of them you have the
longer you live that's right
so today is a day of gratitude another
year in the books
47 dave really yeah
well i wouldn't i thunk it really yeah i
would have thought you're much older
than that
boy folks that's what's called being
reeled in
i just he had me with the hook and i
thought i was gonna
bless me with like 41 or something
yeah so what is this this is your 30 or
your 28th
anniversary of your 29th birthday yeah
not bad it's hard to believe
not bad there we go uh good stuff the
maturity doesn't match the age as we
know we're still working on that
i'm in heavyweight listen if you're
mature you're no good in talk radio so
let me just help you with that
yeah phone number triple eight eight two
five five two two five cali
is gonna start us off in indianapolis hi
callie how are you
hi dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
um so i'm getting married at the end of
august i'm super excited to marry this
man
and we've talked about our deaths from
premarital counseling
i do have a medical debt for my son it
was about 47
000. he was in the pq for a couple weeks
and
i didn't have insurance unfortunately at
the time i do now
so that's taken care of but i was
curious where i put
my medical debt that's actually now in
collections
because it started around covent time so
i couldn't pay it
where would i put that in the baby steps
once we go through financial peace
whenever we get signed up for that
where would i end up putting my son's
medical debt within our other debt
so what do you make i make 57.
what about him he makes 85. and when
you're getting married
august 29th congratulations thank you
how's your baby doing uh he's doing so
much better he is the light of my life
and a light of my fiance's life he's a
lot better now it's just a
sleek incident he aspirated a peanut
so you just uh um you just outlined a
life that is going
really really well and we get to work on
and all we have to work on is some math
stuff so really good yeah
you're in a good place very nice and how
much debt do you have not counting this
i have so we have a car i have a car
that's seven thousand that's our
smallest debt
and then i would say all together i
think we have about
80 000. counting the 47 or not
not counting the 47. what's the rest of
the 80 student loans
he has fewer loans yeah he's a gm after
a hotel and then i have my car
and then i also so during coven i didn't
have insurance and that doesn't help
so i ended up crashing my car and i'm
paying them
12 000 for that okay so but the biggest
number on this is student loans the
biggest number is just being amount
together
okay all right now is the uh
if uh are they attempting to collect are
you paying any payments on the 47
i'm not paying any payments right now
his son was supposed to help me that's
our
his father was supposed to help me
that's actually in our mediation
agreement
that hasn't happened yet um but i was
paying payments and then i stopped and
so
it's gone to collections i called about
it and it's at a collection
a collection agency okay right now but
they're not calling on it no
yeah um here's the thing you probably
can settle this for
say 50 cents on the dollar something
like that if you had the lump
sum and so i would take something like a
number like a 20 000
number and plug that into your debt
snowball wherever it really goes
it sounds like it's before the student
loans but after some of the car stuff
and i'd build up twenty thousand dollars
cash and i would call them is this is
this a single bill
or a total of 47 on medical it's a
single bill it's at a children's
hospital yeah i would also call the
hospital administrator and see if you
can get an in-person meeting with covet
i doubt you can
but anytime you can meet with someone in
person you can plead your case better
and just go
you know i don't have any money
obviously the reason i didn't have i
didn't have
i don't have a insurance reason i have
an insurance i didn't have any money so
if you guys will settle this we we
appreciate the
uh we appreciate the service you gave us
we're thankful for that and
uh we don't want to be anything but but
honorable but we just don't have
47 000 if you guys will take 20 000 i'll
get it to you really really fast
and then make it a priority if you can
get a settlement agreement but any
settlements you do you do
in writing and uh and you never give
a collector of any kind electronic
access to your checking account
because they lie it's a problem
yeah dave what happens if she goes to
the hospital and i love that advice
the hospital has an option there to call
the collection agency i presume and say
hey
we want to pull this back we've talked
to them and we're working this out yeah
they can they
don't usually if you just call them yeah
that's why but an in-person meeting
where you go in not accusing the
hospital of having done something wrong
that's right
like why do you people charge so much
you know none of that and
you're the price problem with you no no
you this is a children's hospital to
help you with your child you're grateful
yeah and uh yeah you start with that
and then you go well you know it's just
a math problem it's not a matter of
intent
i don't have the money and if you guys
will settle this we can get it knocked
out pretty fast if we're going to pay
the whole 47 it's going to take a long
time
yep and you most of the time it's
interesting
even people in the administration in
hospitals
hospitals tend to attract people with
mercy yes
merciful people yes and so not always
but they have a tendency to do that
they move into the medical field for one
reason or another and so
you you oftentimes find someone with
heart uh
but again you're not going in
belligerent no you're not going in
accusing them of having done something
wrong
if you're gonna do that you need an
attorney yes uh but that's
you know because the hospital somehow
malpractice or something like that but
that's not what we're hearing here
no in fact i was going to say if you
have the spirit that you have on this
call
yeah this is a woman who sees the end
she's going to knock it out
she's excited about the days ahead and
you know part of this deal is you got a
deadbeat dude on the other side of this
isn't helping i'd share that story
too and go hey but i'm not relying on
him i'm here
to handle this you help my baby and i
want to do the right thing i think that
conviction
along with the spirit she has is very
attractive it is i mean it's just human
nature and it's proper relationships and
uh but sometimes what happens is we get
afraid um
or we are ashamed and out of those
emotions
uh we we uh project something else
rather than humility
we project anger uh some of the meanest
people in the world are people that are
afraid yes
you know as an example so uh you that's
not her
no and so you know i think you knock out
your car then you knock out the car
debt where you uh hit somebody else
without insurance and then you put
twenty thousand dollars on the list and
then you get to the student loans
and you guys just attack that as fast as
you can any money you get from the ex
uh the data of the child this would be
called gravy on the biscuit because it's
unexpected
and and you'll get there as fast as you
can now i think we can go a little step
further and say
uh if you have if you're out there and
you let's just kind of do a teaching
segment if you have
a bunch of debts in collection
that you haven't paid on it's been 10
months 20 months since you paid on this
credit card
it's been 10 months 20 months since you
paid on this
uh old bad debt from whatever
from a medical bill or whatever else you
make a different list
of those things when you're working your
debt snowball if you got a whole bunch
of that
this is one singular debt and it had an
unusual story around it but
you'd make you'd knock out your existing
debt snowball first
the ones you're current on because that
frees up all those payments you don't
have anymore
and then you work through the defaulted
student loan or the defaulted debt
snowball
one debt at a time settle it
close it in writing no electronic access
to your checking account
do the next one do the next one do the
next one but freeing up those doesn't
free up cash flow because you're not
paying payments on
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's special savings
[Music]
so
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt-free stage
ken funny joins us from jacksonville
florida hey bonnie how are you
hi dave i'm good how are you good to
have you
i'm excited to be here all the way from
jacksonville very cool all the way from
florida how much have you paid off
about forty three thousand dollars love
it how long did that take
almost 14 months good and your range of
income during that time
i started at about 81 and then just got
another promotion so i'm at about 97.50
hey
i like it i like it what do you do for a
living i'm a service executive for a
technology company
so client relations essentially yeah
good good and obviously good at it
very good thank you so what kind of debt
was your 43 000 um
a tax bill six credit cards a personal
loan from my parents
um that was pretty much it no student
loan debt okay
all right how old are you i am 41. 41
yeah and 14 months ago you kind of have
been bopping along with this
like lower back pain kind of debt that's
what that kind of debt is isn't it it's
like
it's you're making enough that it's
small enough that you can almost ignore
it if you take a few advil you know
but but it's but it just keeps coming
back and it's always there is that right
yes it was what happened what broke you
lose um i was planning
a extravagant birthday trip to south
africa for my 40th birthday
yum yeah um a trip i couldn't afford and
i was
taking stock of my life and how to come
to jesus moment with myself
oh it's the old 40th birthday 40th
birthday thing yeah
so um taking a look at my finances and
knowing i couldn't afford
it and then i was in a toxic
relationship at the time i didn't like
my job
basically i wanted to change everything
and was looking for ways to cut costs so
i
enlisted the help of my parents and
asked if i could move in with them for a
year
wow to pay off yeah so they're
and they were one of the debts and so
they said yes yes
i paid them first um
and it was a huge blessing because then
coveted came along and so we
let the boyfriend go first and asked him
to leave and then i got a different job
that i liked a lot more
and no job no boyfriend no apartment
lease no trip to south africa and we're
getting out of debt
right and look at you yes thank you
it's been a long a long journey sounds
cleansing
it was very in more ways than financial
oh yeah career boyfriend the whole thing
i mean it's awesome
this is great yeah i'm very very
grateful yeah i want to ask you a quick
progression there
so you gave us the range of income from
81 to 97.
yeah so when you're in this miserable
job and you change to something you like
is that where we pick up 81 did you get
a
bump there or was it a parallel move i
actually went from 81
my first promotion was to about 87. okay
um
and then the month after i was debt-free
i got another promotion to 97.5
wow and i feel like god was just saying
thank you for being a good steward of
what you have
and now you don't have to struggle as
much anymore a little tip of the hat
from the holy spirit
yeah how much did the loving the work
really enjoy in the work how much did
that play into the
any mindset or emotion and performance
that led to what you believe
did it lead to the promotion is my
question do you think i think i was just
hyper focused so
everything else that was positive that i
was drawing to myself
i think just led to a job promotion
um it was more so my boss i didn't like
if i'm telling the truth um that's not a
surprise
people leave leaders not companies right
yeah the work was okay
i'm actually at the same company i'm
just um have jumped apartments so
good for you yeah so good much better
not surprising dave you hear that all
the time yeah focus
yep focus to get out of debt led to
professional
gains not just well and another thing
was you cleaned all this junk out of
your life
and you were in the process of cleaning
junk out of your life of different kinds
and that
that just this is such a great story i'm
so proud of you
thank you your parents got to be proud
of you i hope so they're here with me
they came with you to cheer right yes
they did and my niece kristabel as well
all right very good very good well
that's cool that makes a nice nashville
trip
not south africa but a good time not
south africa i told my parents when this
was all over i would buy them a vacation
so i'm sending them on a cruise for
their 50th wedding anniversary next year
that's awesome that's more fun than
going yourself
yes i'm very excited that's awesome very
cool
so 14 months 43 000 that's pretty
intense
yeah it was what do you tell people the
key is living on a budget for sure
um for a while i did davish i took
financial piece years ago
but like you said i had enough to manage
the chaos it was just sort of my
juggling system
and now it's more of a this is why i
have hope
and focusing on investing and planning
my future
and when i decided to do this i was just
in a really hopeless place and
struggling with depression
and going through a breakup so i was a
hot mess when i moved into my parents
also
but i just i had a lot of shame um
dealing with thoughts that i hadn't been
a good steward of what god had given me
and i know i was capable of more so i
just prayed
that you know i could be the person i
wanted to be i wanted to be someone my
family would be proud of
and that one day i'd stand here they are
all that's awesome they are
they are proud of you and we are too and
that shame flipped to conviction then
and it's game on
yeah yeah yeah shame is destructive
conviction to get your button gear
yeah yeah well well
i'm so proud of you well done very
powerful
wow what i i you know your whole life
has changed and it's
the that piece is just part of it it was
just part of it part of it but it almost
precipitated it in a sense it started
the whole
ball rolling it did it did i feel like
it really came to a head
and i was unrecognizable to myself
and that really started my journey um to
be gonzalo tents and get out of debt and
change everything
um but yeah i'm happier now than i've
ever been it's the highest base salary
i've ever had i just feel like
it's a reward for being a good steward
of what i've been given
you're free yes and you're generally and
you're generous
yes and you're in a much healthier place
all the way around much of the area so
when the emotion
just grabbed you there because you you
were talking about
i i envisioned getting to this moment
here you are you did it
you are standing on the debt free stage
i want you to tell people because the
emotion's still all over you it was hard
is it worth it standing there moments
before you do your scream was it worth
it
absolutely absolutely i would say for
anyone listening that's struggling
you know it's hard to hold on your hope
especially day after day like
even in the 40 you know plus thousand
dollars i also
paid cash for about 3 500 of car repairs
in that time
so anytime something would go wrong with
my car i was so discouraged and
you know i had a plan for i will beat up
free on this day and then something else
would go wrong
and i listened to your podcast and i
would hear the debt free screams and
just think you know if i just keep going
just one one more day
i you know i can do this and um
and then the chains start to drop off
and you see the light at the end of the
tunnel
it's not an oncoming train and
um here i am you are there i'm here
i'm just going to leave and let her do
the next segment yeah yeah she could
take over the rest of the hour
i'm just i think everybody's signing up
for financial peace university right now
this is i'm amazed this is so powerful
well done very very well done
all right bonnie we've got a copy of the
legacy journey for you because that for
sure is your next
chapter in your story the chapter of
generosity and legacy and
control and destiny and that's where
you're headed you're
you're you're a powerhouse you're
amazing thank you you grabbed every part
of your life
up by the neck and shook it and made it
behave and it was very very powerful
good
it's an honor to meet you and also a
copy of the total money makeover for you
to give away because you haven't shut up
talking about this and somebody that you
know needs a copy of it that you've been
bothering about this stuff
and um we're just so proud of you and i
know your mom and dad are
very very well done all right it's
bonnie from jacksonville florida
43 000 paid off in
14 months making 81-97 what a great
story
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream
three
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
absolutely fabulous unbelievable
what a great story this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five
five two two five you guys jump in we'll
talk about your life
and your money if you're in debt we know
it can feel like you're fighting a
losing battle with those bills
sometimes you can feel stuck like bonnie
in our last debt-free scream there
you may wonder if you're ever going to
get ahead well you can you can get
control you can grab things by the neck
like she did you can build the life you
want we will show you how
in financial peace university millions
and millions and millions of people have
learned the proven plan
to work out of debt and into wealth in
financial peace university
and of course you're gonna be sticking
to a budget that's part of the plan
and you'll have the premium version of
our budgeting tool every dollar
both entre elite are both of every
dollar and
financial peace university are available
at ramsey plus you can start a free
trial of ramsey plus
and end this constant battle with and
for your money
just text trial to 33 789
text trial two three three seven
eight nine sarah is with us in los
angeles hi sarah welcome to the ramsay
show
well hello dave how are you better than
i deserve what's up
uh my husband and i are on baby step two
we've paid off 23 000
and have another 22 to go cool my mom
keeps asking me to
help her and my dad figure out their
budget
help them start on the ramsay plan i
just finished reading the total money
makeover and i gave her my copy
good um and now it's leading to us
fighting
my dad is 57 and my mom's 54. my dad
wants to retire soon
they keep trying to convince me that
their 800 credit score is good
my dad doesn't want to stop the 15 that
he's currently investing
um even though they're just shy of 110
dollars in debt yeah well there's no
reason to find
that's what i say do what i said that's
what i say
yeah well so i mean if they don't want
to do it they don't have to do it
well that's what i keep saying i'm not
going to fight over it
it's just you guys do whatever you want
to do
you ask me so i told you what we were
doing i gave you a copy of the book but
you don't have to do it it's not a law
well that's what i'm trying to say and
then they turn around and they're like
oh well but we need to get out of debt
and we want to retire
yeah but i mean i showed you how you got
you got to decide which one you want to
do you can't be both
if you want to know how i did it i
showed you how i did it i used the total
money makeover baby steps this is how i
did it
i don't know how to tell you how to do
it other than that that's the only way i
know this is you talking okay
and so and i'm not gonna fight with you
you guys can either do it or not do it
i'm gonna love you either way you're my
mom and dad
i'm gonna love you even if you're stupid
don't say it don't say that but you can
think that
yeah right no they'll kill me i can't
say that i know i know but you see what
i'm saying
that's what's going through your head
right but here's the thing the fight the
fight
comes when they are trying to convince
you to not do it
the ramsay stuff the baby steps and the
fight comes
when you are trying to convince them to
do the baby steps
so the best way you can convince them is
to continue to do it properly yourself
and win
and they'll con and it sets an example
for them but you can't make people do
stuff
yeah that's true you make little kids do
stuff but you can't make grown people do
stuff
and you can only make little kids do
stuff you can only make little kids do
stuff until you leave the room
that's right sarah one of the things
sarah i hear the tension for you because
they keep asking you
and you're so passionate you're so
convicted on this journey
that you can't just answer a question
you know and i think that that's where
there may be some tension there and i
think dave's absolutely right
i think if they keep asking a question
you go um i'm not sure i'll text you
later tonight
i think it's on page 87 of chapter three
or whatever and just stay out of the
communication if you're feeling your
tension rise
uh because of your tremendous conviction
then you're gonna have to just when they
ask a question
say i'll look it up it's in this chapter
it's in chapter five or it's in chapter
six or whatever it is
and give them the answer but don't get
involved in the back and forth opinion
stuff
because dave's right i don't want to do
that okay yeah great
sure that's cool i don't want i don't
want to stop putting money in my 401k
okay i mean i you know
i if somebody calls me up on the air
here
and i'm the guy okay it's not just like
a theory for me this is i'm the guy that
wrote it and did it for me and tens of
millions of people
right if somebody calls me up here on
the air and wants to argue with me i'll
talk to him for a minute or two
and then i just go to the next caller
i'm not gonna have a debate with
somebody about this because i'm right
i'm not gonna have a discussion about it
i mean it's i mean i'm not right about
everything
but this stuff i mean 20 million people
have done this stuff
under my direction so it's not like it's
wrong anymore
you know it's not it's not like an
opinion it's not a theory by a broke
college professor this is
this is we do this and this is i may not
be able to do anything else but this i
can do so i'm not going to argue with
you about it
if you don't agree with me you're just
what's known as wrong and america is a
great place you're allowed to be wrong
yeah and so you know you just have to be
kind about it and have a little bit of
that in your head
a little bit of those kinds of tapes
almost sarcasm playing in your head and
you just kind of
don't be mean and don't be unkind and
just go dad
if you don't want to do that that's okay
i understand i love you
this is what plan i'm doing you are a
grown man you get to choose what you're
going to do
and i'm going to love you either way
yeah and that creates
the emotional boundary that you need you
need that
you need to be able to put a boundary
out there and go we're doing it we're
all in for us
mom and dad they got their big boy pants
on and they're big girl pants so at some
point
uh don't get sucked into the back and
forth on it i'm not going to try to make
you do it
and please don't try to make me not do
it that's right there there's your
clearest boundary
yeah and because either one of those are
going to cause a problem and we're going
to have it we're going to have conflict
and i don't want to have conflict with
you i just want to love you
and there's no point in the conflict
because you're grown people you're
allowed to do
whatever you want to do even if you're
wrong i mean i got
i got relatives that vote wrong goal
and and i love them anyway that's true
i'm sure it's okay they just don't know
how to vote
and you know no amount of talking to
them helps either no
so i just quit i quit arguing with them
a long time ago and i i just know my
vote got cancelled out by so-and-so
you know that's they just don't know how
to vote and so you just can't there's
something you just can't argue about
done doing good jimmy's with us in
california hi jimmy how are you
doing great i heard you did better than
i deserve how can we help
i'm calling because i have a quick
question uh my wife and i are on baby
step number two
uh we recently just sold our condo uh
made a profit of around seventy five
thousand dollars
uh in the bank right now we have 185. uh
the issue is we have a hundred and
seventy thousand dollars in student
loans
uh my question is would you save a large
chunk of that we're looking at a home
around six hundred thousand
uh save twenty percent of that for a
down payment or would you pay
place a large sum of that towards the
student loan debt did i understand you
have 185 in the bank 170 in student loan
debt
yes yes you did okay uh well what we
teach folks is don't buy a house until
your debt free and have an emergency
fund okay
so i think you're renting for a while
because i think you just used 170 of
your 185 to become debt free
yeah ow you're not going to do that are
you
well i mean crying he's laughing like
it's the most ludicrous thing he's ever
heard
[Laughter]
well you know as ludicrous as it sounds
it also kind of
did just for a second when i said that
did you feel kind of free
yes yes that would be amazing yeah i
mean you have to admit down inside your
stomach that something was set free when
i said that down inside your soul
something was set free
because that 170 looks like it's
insurmountable
it looks like freaking mount everest and
for just a second
i placed you on top of mount everest and
you were cheering for just a second
and then you started rolling your eyes
and going i think this guy's crazy
hey jimmy jimmy are you jimmy do you
have a good job
you gainfully employed yeah so i'm an ic
registered nurse and my wife is an
emergency department here's what i
what's your household income
uh we are around 160. oh my god
jimmy here's a fun exercise for you you
and your wife tonight dinner okay
write down what it would look like what
would your financial situation look like
if you paid the 170 off you had 15k
you're living in an rv right yeah and
then you got
really good income what would life look
like i think you just got to get over it
yeah you gotta write it down on paper
and look how fast could you save a
hundred grand
oh my goodness um we paid off two
this was before i knew about your
program yeah we paid off like two forty
thousand dollar cars and
like within a year yeah so i think you
can save a hundred grand a year
[Applause]
and i think you're gonna be in a house
by this time next year
and you have an emergency fund and no
student loan debt
and you're gonna look back 10 years
later and go that crazy guy on the radio
is right
because if you don't do this you're
going to limp
for a decade hey you tell people what to
do all the time in your business
and they either do it or they don't this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host ken coleman
ramsey personality number one
best-selling author is my co-host today
you jump in we'll talk about your life
and your money it's a free call
at triple eight eight two five five
two two five if you've not heard the ken
coleman show it is broadcast on siriusxm
75 plus radio stations and a podcast and
a youtube channel every day
it's all about finding your path
to your dream job finding your path
through your career and ken coaches
people looking for new jobs how to move
up in their current jobs how to find
their giftings and align with it and it
is working so ken talks about the
workplace all the time
ken one of the things i'm seeing right
now is this all this talk
about burnout and coming back from
the pandemic a lot of people are going
back to jobs that they hated and they
realize
now how bad they hate them and they're
quitting like crazy we're seeing a
huge number of people quitting their
jobs they call some people are calling
it the great resignation
but if you ask someone if they love the
work they do they oftentimes say yes and
they really they're lying
why do they do that well there's
something about what other people think
you know we've seen this happen
more so in the pandemic than i think any
time in modern history where
we just are so worried about being
criticized and questioned
and so it's almost a little bit of the
old golden handcuffs you got a good job
a good benefits
good pay and the idea of moving on to
something else is
is almost scoffed at and you know we
talk a lot about this
on the ken coleman show we've got seven
stages a very clear path and stage five
is is one that people really need to
grasp grasp certainly people that listen
to this show
it's called get promoted and this is the
idea of moving up the professional
ladder and there's two benefits dave to
getting promoted
certainly when you get promoted most of
the time
you're talking about getting more income
and that helps us with
uh whatever stage that we're in in the
baby steps right that bigger shovel
is applied throughout the baby steps
right we always need the bigger shovel
but the other thing dave is that
we long to do work that really matters
deeply to us we want to be challenged
and if we're not getting promoted
if we're not growing professionally then
we're not growing
personally you're dying if you're not
growing you're dying there's no there is
no there is no i'm going to sit here and
do the same work for 38 years that's
right
because your work deteriorates oh yeah
you cannot do the same work for 38 years
at some point you you master it you're
going to do better or you're going to do
worse yeah
you're not going to do the same that's
right and so if you did now listen my my
parents generation
certainly my grandfather's generation
the greatest generation they would work
the same job for 30 to 40 years those
days are
over the job is okay but the work's
different the work has changed
and then you know what's really cool
these younger generations certainly
the millennials begin to introduce this
but the the
generation after them these gen z kids
they really want to do something that
matters deeply to them
personal values and i think that's a
really nice thing to see but
this idea of well i'm burned out
and i don't want to do that at work
anymore that's not true uh dave i just
posted something
last week on instagram at ken coleman
and it was a clip from the show the ken
coleman show where i was talking about
a news article that shows there is a
huge percentage of teachers that are
planning to resign this year and next
year
because of the administrative demands on
them
the focus on on um aptitude scores
uh and things of that nature that have
nothing to do with the kids grades it's
all about
teaching social agendas instead of
teaching academics that's the third
piece they
now are being forced to teach something
that is politically a real hot potato
and so they're going oh i i can't do it
anymore and
and what you have to understand there is
if that's you no matter what profession
you're in
you still love the work but the
environment itself is what you need to
change
not necessarily the profession
understand that you could be
what i call in the sweet spot where
you're using your talent to do work you
love to produce results of matter
but if you're in a crappy environment uh
that'll get old quick and you'll want to
change location so dave in this great
resignation
that they're reporting that you
mentioned 40 percent their economists
are predicting 40 percent of the
american workforce will change jobs in
2021.
good lord don't don't please please
please please
don't just move uh to something else
because of a paycheck
make sure that you love the work because
i can't tell you many times i'll get a
call from somebody say well i got a
promotion ken and i took it
and i'm miserable yeah you gotta love
the work
and you gotta care about the results of
the work don't come to ramsey solutions
and work here
if you don't care deeply about providing
hope
through practical content that is
transformational
don't come here because that's what we
bleed over here
and and if you can't get excited about
that it's just a job
for you and we don't want you and you
won't want to be here yeah
that's exactly right and it is it's
actually a
a job requirement here that's got to be
a crusader that you care
yeah and so we're hiring 300 folks this
year and
one of the things we're interviewing for
is uh are you going to care deeply
and do you care deeply about what it is
you're going to be doing and how and
where you're going to be doing it and so
uh because i
the last thing i want to be giving
people my money who don't care yeah
and then because they always mail it in
yeah they're not creative they're not
productive they don't they're not game
on
it will be a train stop for them yeah
and i don't have time it's too expensive
to hire people and bring them in here
and move them out it's just too
expensive
it's too expensive emotionally that's
right because i i i fall in love with i
love the people and then they leave and
it breaks my heart and so i can't you
know i'd rather just get folk that
actually karen are going to stay that's
a better plan and so that ought to be
you whether you're coming here or
anywhere else is what ken's saying yeah
don't have the train stop mentality have
the ladder mentality all right so i am
i am moving towards that dream job where
i am just absolutely in my sweet spot
i'm using my top talents
to do tasks and functions or fill a role
that i look
forward to and it creates a result that
personally connects to my values these
are the things i want to contribute
that has to be it has to be
always the litmus test for what am i
choosing and this idea of getting
promoted dave stage five
is all about moving up the ladder
because here's what happens we saw it
with our debt free screamer
we see it all the time when i get
focused
on on just the debt snowball we see
people get promoted and make more money
but what if you were focused on not just
making more money but doing work that
you love
you're going to see income and impact
dave
both of them move up and that's what
everybody longs to do is to make a
difference
instead of a j-o-b and it occurs to me
that even in a given position
you can everything's changing so fast
quickly the technology's changing the
methodology is changing the delivery
mechanisms are changing
i mean we didn't you know i couldn't
even spell podcast a few years ago and
now
12 million of you listen to this podcast
you know uh
on this show and we've had 10 million on
the radio for years
but uh it you know so you all of a
sudden
we've got young people that were
broadcast people that are now podcast
people all in this building working on
our podcast
all the time and so you could be you
could have started here
uh and you're still doing the same job
but you're doing in a different way with
new technology and have gotten
and that is a form of promotion
absolutely and so there is a clear path
we're excited dave we got a big
announcement coming soon a book that's
going to reveal
all seven stages in the clear path to
doing work you love
very exciting ken coleman ramsey
personality is my co-host today this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
oh
still on baby step number one huh how'd
you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit chministries.org budget
don't worry it's worth it
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today nathan is in richmond
virginia hi nathan how can we help
hi how are you doing better than i
deserve what's going on
okay so here's what i got going on um
i'm 25 years old
i'm getting money from my father who
recently passed away
it's going to be over 200 000 i'm not
the best in money management
i've heard the saying it takes money to
make money should i invest this money
into a business should i save this money
what should i do if i want to become a
millionaire by the time i'm in my 30s
[Music]
how long does your dad pass away nathan
um he passed away a couple months ago
i'm sorry y'all close um we were pretty
close he had dimension alzheimer's so
i didn't see him um too often because he
was in a
assisted living facility sure and i
lived across the country so he was in
arizona with my sisters and then i
lived over here in virginia so you're
getting 200 000
cash is not over that
it is just over that yeah
i'm not sure the exact number i mean
it's just it's not it's not a piece of
property or something else it's just
it's a investments or cash that's going
to come to you liquid that you're going
to do whatever you want to do with it
yes like my brother's going to hand me a
check gotcha okay
and uh what do you make a year now
so a year i used to make around i'd say
35 000 a year
okay all right so here's what i would
tell you
um you're calling very very
wisely to start to uh gather some wisdom
about something you don't know anything
about
you have never driven a car before and
someone just gave you car keys
right cool and you you go well i i hear
these things go fast
right and so uh you know that that
and yet if you remember the first time
you got behind the wheel of a car
uh it was both freeing because you could
now go
places and control your own destiny and
it was
uh terrifying and if you don't have both
of those feelings with this process
you're not wise right
okay so uh i'll start with it takes
money to make money uh is
not a true statement that's a statement
that broke people say
as an excuse to not become broke people
can you make money using money sure
but actually the vast majority of people
who build wealth do not build it because
someone handed them two hundred thousand
dollars they built it because of their
habits and their character
okay so that's you so here's what we're
gonna do we're going to
just what number one i tell you to do is
just slow way down
i would want you to move along the
spectrum from exciting to boring over
towards boring
your job is to manage this money
your job as if it's someone else's money
and you're managing it for them
your job first is not to lose it
your job second is to maximize it
but most people when they get handed the
keys to the car
step on the gas and mean it meaning
they're they think their job is to
maximize it and they end up losing it
so yeah people that end up in your
situation get money lose it very often
because they make the mistake of they
think it has to be exciting it has to be
sexy it has to be wild has to be crazy
because if i don't maximize it i'm doing
something wrong it takes money to make
money we all know that and so i'm going
to invest
it over here and i'm going to do this
i'm going to do that and i'm going to do
this wrong
slow down number one rule nathan don't
put money in something you don't
understand don't put money in something
someone else tells you is a good idea
and they sound like they're really smart
people around the money business and
i've been around at 40
years there are a lot of enthusiastic
ignoramuses
they mean well but they're dumber than a
rock
and they're excited about and they're
excited about their stupidity
and they will put you in stuff they'll
put you in stuff man
and all your broke friends also got an
opinion already don't they
yeah and here's another piece too i
started
a meat company but the thing about it
when i started this meat company
it's not my passion because i was so
money hungry
to where i let money kind of consume my
mind
of oh i need to make i need to make
money i need to be this by the time i'm
on this agenda
i chase things that weren't my passion
and then
i realized as i got into it i'm like
shoot i don't want to do this anymore
okay so let me let's take a couple
things number one we can work on your
career
and that would be a good use of a little
of this money
if it got you into your passion i'll
hand off to ken in a minute and let him
work on that okay
but then thing two uh here's a rule
if you were to invest this money and not
touch it
in good growth stock mutual funds and if
it made 10
rate of return on average in seven years
it would double you would have 400
and you would be what 29 years old right
no how do you say you're 25 25 yeah yeah
okay so you'll be 32 years old
and fi in seven more years would double
again it'd be eight hundred thousand
and in seven more years it would double
again and it'd be a million six
and that is a boring never touch it
investment program you're probably not
gonna do exactly that
but i want a little of that in the
formula here my brother
okay where you go have a life and you
pretend you don't have this money and
you let it grow and double and grow and
double and grow and double
and so here my my last piece of
instruction before ken helps you on the
career side
is uh i want you to go to daveramsey.org
or to ramseysolutions.com and click on
smart vester sit down with the
smartvestor pro
and they will teach you about mutual
funds
and then you can decide how much of this
needs to go into your career changes
and how much of it needs to go into
mutual funds
and that just sit there and just double
so ken yeah real quick question here
is the meat company that you started is
that what's getting you the 35 000
a year yes all right and so you don't
want to do that what do you want to do i
know you got some ideas or one clear
idea what is it that you really want to
do
so i really want to do fitness um
because
even in the times when i was at my
lowest i always stuck to it
yeah and it seems like it was like
introduced to me
great at a young age so is that uh is
that a fitness coach
trainer is that what we're talking about
so i want to compete in shows and i want
to launch
um i want to be able to get a following
through the instagram and be able to
launch a business online and help people
um reach their fitness
goals yeah online because everything is
online now
sure um and also you know even in person
but
doing it online it gives you that
freedom to do the travel all right
so let me make sure i heard this right
you want to be a fitness competitor and
then eventually develop some type of
online
and in-person training business that's a
two-parter am i right
yes okay so here's the deal i'ma caution
you on this being a fitness competitor
is a whole different ball game we only
can make money when we win
so if that's the first goal you're going
to need a day job
so you got to sit down and go now what's
the best strategy here's what i would
challenge you to think through
i would you're clear on what you want to
do that's stage one of my seven stages
stage twos get qualified
so you need to answer the question what
is it that i need to do to get qualified
to train people online now online
there's no technical qualification you
just gotta have good content that people
say all right i'm going to watch this
guy
and i'm going to train the way he trains
but if you want to do it one-on-one
there's some qualification that you need
how much is that going to cost you how
long is that going to take we're going
to have to have a day job still
in all of this process so if you've got
the meat
personal trainer it could be a personal
trainers where i would go into so get
qualified to do that get in the
proximity
that's it start doing that and then
compete and any money we make competing
and the online business it's going to
grow over time
i would get in the field work for a gym
and have somebody else pay you to do the
training so that you can
move from meat company into this job and
not interrupt the income because dave we
don't want him to touch
yeah this 200 000
a year's worth of 2 000 a month yeah
i want you to pay yourself out of a
little savings account 2 000 each month
for one year during that year i want you
to develop a real
group of one-on-one personal training
clients that pay you well and you use
that money to eat with
then you will also perfect your training
techniques meanwhile you get to work out
like a crazy person
for your own uh competition goals
and uh let's build a training business
then build an online business
while we're competing and i think that's
an
order and a way to get at this and use a
little bit of the money to do that
and let's invest the rest of it and not
don't be spending a bunch of money on
unproven business ideas or trying to buy
a
franchise on a business out of a box
you're not in a position to do that yet
you got to get some
more notches in your belt this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
do
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt-free stage evan
and alyssa are with us hey guys how are
you
doing great good welcome where do you
guys live germantown wisconsin
milwaukee area that's right yeah good
good to have you guys welcome
all the way to nashville to do a
debt-free scream how much have you paid
off
103 000 just just north of 103 thousand
dollars
good how long did that take you about 36
months
good and your range of income during
that time uh
it ranged from 120 to 170. good what do
you guys do for a living
i work in a sales executive for a large
insurance company
and then i was working at a bank and
with financial advisors okay
good very cool so both of your numbers
people around the numbers were oh for
sure what kind of debt was the 103
yeah the majority was student loans we
had a
2013 camaro sitting in the driveway and
uh
2018 honda civic that we got rid of
along the way as well but the majority
student loans done a little bit of
credit card debt on top of it so you
sold both those cars
uh we sold the honda civic actually to
our grandparents that kind of kicked us
off and
we're thankful for that i think they
paid a little bit above market just to
help us on the way that's nice yeah yeah
and then uh cabarro ended up turning
into a
2005 sierra that we still have to this
day payton paid full so
oh wow okay wow good for you so
what happened 36 months ago what starts
this journey for y'all
yeah you know we we pretty much were
just thinking hey we're going to be
we're going to be cuffed to these
student loans for the next 10 years and
these car payments the next five and
never put too much thought to it but
the place i worked at the time a friend
of mine joel i know he's i know he's
listening back home
he came to me one day and said he ever
hear this book total money makeover
no this guy dave ramsey said no he said
well
you know i was listening yesterday and
this uh this girl paid off ninety
thousand dollars of student loans in two
years and there's
people paying off their mortgages in
four to five years so
um immediately that got my that my
offsets the light bulb goes yeah there's
a different way to do this
yeah that'd be cool that's what your
mind says that'd be neat
how do you do that so i run home and i'm
all jacked up you know and
uh bring the idea to alyssa and wow you
know why would we do that while we put
ourselves through that stress and
we went to a restaurant locally jotted
down a bunch of notes about what was
coming out every month and
then on a different piece of paper wrote
down a bunch of goals that we had over
the next
you know five ten years and we noticed
we can't have three thousand dollars
going out every month the student loan
payments and debt payments
and accomplish these things at the same
time so we gotta we gotta figure
something out okay
but i'll be honest i was not fully
bought in sure
so it took a i told them i will you know
entertain this for you
and we'll see how it goes for the next
couple months okay um
but after the you know these couple
months it was like
why have we never lived like this before
it really
it was hard at first but it wasn't you
know a huge life change i didn't
it didn't kill you no no we're still
here and you can see your way out
exactly if you can see your way out and
it doesn't kill you you'll do it
yeah so you went picked up the total
money makeover book yourself after the
restaurant i did yep yep and that's
that's been passed through the family
now so um that's another thing about our
midwest upbringing it's a conservative
you know we don't talk about money but
alyssa and i going through this journey
has all of a sudden opened up those
lines of
communication our family and her family
and it's just been a serious blessing
for for everybody that's
come in contact with us so throughout
the journey so
it's been really special yeah you've
inspired people it's what amounts to
yeah that's why we're here you know
we're not just here to celebrate our our
debt free screen but
if we can make an impact on one person
listening in i mean it's
the weight of this i i have a newfound
respect for folks in on that lobby
waiting for their debt free scream we
were laughing
crying over the last you know hour or so
so
and getting nervous about getting the
microphone yeah yeah you're doing great
though you're doing great
okay i've got a relationship question
yeah uh because
for a married couple you know it's this
has got to be a joint deal
and alyssa i love what you said you said
okay we go to the the diner or wherever
you go and your job we got two pieces of
paper okay
and alyssa i love it you said well i i
wasn't bought in but i was like all
right i'm open-minded would you
speak to the importance of that
relationship component if one of the
spouses is like i don't know yet
but given it a chance because that
seemed to be really big for you because
you saw it
yeah i would say i mean you know evan
has a lot of crazy ideas
i think but go evan
this time i was like you know this
actually sounds like something that
would help us in the future
um when he brought the ideas to me i
just didn't want to have to do a big
life change i think it's scary
you know you all of a sudden i can't you
know go get
something at the store i feel like i
can't spend money i didn't want to have
to feel guilty about making purchases
but when he really showed me you know
and we started doing it it was a lot
easier than i thought there was things
that we didn't even know where half of
our spending was
going yeah so when we really wrote it
down and
having me bought in bought our whole
relationship even to the next level i
feel like
um you know we were both on the same
page um i do know some people who want
to
pay off all their debt and they don't
have their spouse you know bought in and
i said it
may not work you know you really have to
have that person that
has the same drive as you we'd both log
our spending you know in the app
um you both have to be determined to do
it yeah
yeah you weren't resistant but you just
wanted to prove out because he brought
you other schemes and scams
sharon says that she says you're
scheming and scamming
no i'm not doing either one i'm just
having a discussion here woman
a big driving factor you know one of the
things on that list was
she's always wanted to become a
stay-at-home mom when we had kids
and you know anybody that's ever seen
her be a mother will tell you she's the
she's
built for it you know she is the best
mother that you'll ever see
and um as a result of this pro this
program that we stuck to over the last
three years we've been able to
accomplish that goal
for her and um yeah that got her on
board you know once you start talking
like that
yeah there you go that's great yeah you
know here's another thing you
you you made it personal for her it
wasn't just about your big idea and that
you got fired up from the book you
tapped into her
future desired future her dreams look at
the tears on her she loves being obama i
mean that's what it's about that's
financial peace right there for sure
for you not to get uh i'm hoping i can
get through without getting emotional
like her but
you asked the last debt-free scream
what made it worth it for you right
there was a situation we were we were
coming up towards the very end of our
journey
and we had our son in daycare she was
working part-time just to make some more
money so we could kind of
speed this thing along and again her
whole
goal was become a stay-at-home mother
our second baby was due in a month at
this point
yep so we're in stork mode as you guys
call it i think we had like
30 grand sitting in the bank account and
we're just working out the numbers to
figure out how we can make this all
happen at once have the baby debt free
stay at home you know and about a month
before we were about to pull our son
from daycare we get a call
it's a great daycare we still have
friends there uh to this day that we
that we love talking to on a regular
basis and
we'd be we'd go back there you know but
they had a situation where
our two-year-old was left out they go to
the playground
they left our son out you know it was it
was a really short period of time it's
like five minutes he was
like hidden on a playhouse where they
couldn't see him and um
you know i think about my boy being out
there alone and scared and
um we had and they called you and told
you about it
they admitted it yeah they were they
called us you know it was a regulation
put on them by the state and they stuck
to it
we appreciate that and we're still good
friends with the owner of that
yeah well i mean everybody makes a
mistake but that goes okay it's done yep
i'm done and because of where we were
you could you could pull the trigger
yeah i got i got a call at 10 o'clock in
the morning i was
at that daycare at 11 taking my son out
he's never gone back and
when people ask alyssa what she does for
a living and then my son's next to her
he says i stay home with mommy
and great you know it's uh it's just
it's just such a
it's such a the weight was it's really
rewarding that we were able to do that
and now he can
you know i can hang out with him every
day and we do fun things every day
that's worth 103 000 and anything you
sacrifice to get rid of it all day
yeah that's a that's a check well
written right there well done guys
i love it you guys are amazing thank you
you're inspiring
so fun so fun so the key well we ain't
even got time i'm not gonna do it i'm
gonna give you a copy of the total
total money makeover to give away so
somebody that's at a restaurant
somewhere
doing their goals probably needs a copy
of that book you're gonna run into them
and we'll give you a copy of the legacy
journey because you definitely have
changed your family tree
in so many different ways in this story
so inspiring so well done you guys thank
you thank you all right evan
and alyssa milwaukee wisconsin area 103
000 paid off in 36 months make it 120 to
170.
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream
three
[Applause]
you want to stay home with your kiddos
[Applause]
touchdown this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight
eight two five five two two five
our question today comes from blinds.com
they have a 100
satisfaction guarantee that means even
if you mismeasure you pick the wrong
color
they will remake your window blinds for
free they have free samples free
shipping
new promos all the time always use the
magic word the promo code ramsey
to get you a deal today's question dave
comes from javier
in california he writes in i currently
have a job in construction management
which pays a hundred thousand dollars a
year plus bonuses
my dream since i was a kid was to become
a police officer but the money i've been
making
has pushed me away from this goal i
don't get the satisfaction with my
current job that i think i would
have as a police officer but i'm scared
to make a change
which might be a mistake what should i
do javier
you should follow your heart on this but
before we follow the heart let's do a
little bit more
research what i call clarify and verify
you've probably done this but i'd love
for you to talk to a couple police
officers who really love their work
and this is over coffee could be over
zoom whatever and sit down with them
and learn what do they love most about
the work
what do they like the least and let's
just do a little simple
almost term paper-like research with
real men and women who are winning and
love
being a police officer once we get that
information that's to clarify
your heart is going to verify verify and
say hey this is something i need to do
now it's all about getting qualified
and so you know what that journey looks
like or you need to find out from them
so what is
actually involved what do i need to do
to get qualified what's that process
going to look like
and now we have a clear path to getting
qualified and so you make really good
money
you save up for any kind of cost here in
the qualification stage
and you go for it you're going to make
the transition and here's the deal dave
i know this that anytime somebody makes
a change even when their heart like
javier is saying
he's always wanted to be a police
officer to protect and to serve
but it's scary when we don't know what
the journey might look like
and so when we go figure out what the
journey is going to look like
in getting qualified and then what does
it look like
there's two pieces to that to me
listening to you explain it through
it feels like that um if i get real
clear of exactly what it looks like when
i get there
and then i get really clear on exactly
what it's going to take
to get there that's exactly right the
fear goes away yeah
because now we know oh okay i'm going to
have to get physically fit because i got
to pass a test for this so i've got some
goals i've got to hit i'm gonna have to
go through the academy
through the academy maybe three four
months and then maybe there's a six
month probation period where they bring
me in whatever
that particular department looks like
that's what we're talking about what
does it take to actually get in
and then when you're doing the job yeah
here's what the glorious parts are but
here's the inglorious parts
yeah you know like i know one lady that
kept saying she wanted to be a nurse and
then she went and
shadowed a nurse for two days and she
went ew i don't want to do that that's
right that's the clarify verify once we
actually see
what it's like what are the best parts
yeah there's some ride-alongs with some
patrol guys
you know we had a policeman call me
today on the coleman show earlier today
and he was wanting to transition because
of the environment
that unfortunately exists today in
america
around policemen and it's not the case
for everybody but this certainly a
really rough environment
and so i really pressed him on it and i
said what do you love most about being a
police officer and his answer was
i really like being a part of saving
someone's life whether i'm doing it
or assisting an emt or a fireman or
whatever because it's really about
protecting people for me
and and i think that what he was trying
to do is say hey ken should i leave
because of the environment and i said
if you can find something else that
allows you to do the work of protecting
or caregiving then yes but if not
stay and in this situation before you
make that move
you really want to clarify and verify
does this set my heart on fire am i
doing work that i love
am i producing results that matter
deeply to me very simple questions
and if you look into it the answers take
away the fear of the unknown because we
know
oh this is what it's going to be like
and this is what it's gonna take to get
there
now i can wrap my brain around it just
like dave for years is giving you folks
seven baby steps
oh a thousand dollars baby step one i
gotta put a thousand dollars for rainy
day
you know the either the debt snowball oh
there's a plan
absent of a plan fear will paralyze us
yep yeah but knowledge gives you power
absolutely when you when you know what
it's going to be like when you get there
and you know exactly what the steps are
the fear largely dissipates it really
does but most of your fear comes from
the unknown yes sir
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five rachel's in
orange county california hi rachel
welcome to the ramsey show
hi thank you so much this is like my
fourth and fifth time calling and i'm
excited every time
well we're honored to have you again how
can we help thank you
okay so um in january this year i paid
off
two car collections that i had from
about six to seven years ago
um and so one of them is not on my
credit report anymore
the other one for toyota i had to
dispute twice
and it finally shows that i paid a
lesser amount than what was actually
due however it's still showing up on my
credit report
and it's saying it'll be on there until
february of next year
that's because that's what happened
okay so they keep that on record for a
year
i mean as long you you settled it for
less than was owed right
correct i got it all in writing yeah so
and and they're reporting
they're reporting it accurately although
it is a negative report
okay is that correct yes okay yeah you
can't do anything about something that's
reported accurately
okay but they're they're saying it's
going to drop off in a year
yeah it says on file until february of
2022.
oh great because yeah but another way
they can another way they can choose to
do it is
seven years from the date of last
activity on the account and the last
activity on the account was when you
settled it
it could have been seven years from the
other day but the good news is it's
about to run out anyway so it's going to
go away
but there's not really anything you can
do about it because you can only dispute
things on a credit bureau report that
are inaccurate
correct and this is accurate so you're
stuck with it and the great news is it's
going to go away
automatically in a year anyway because
apparently that's seven years ago
that you had this repo or had the
problem or established the account or
something
because it's a seven year rule the only
thing that stays on your credit bureau
report longer than seven years is a
chapter seven bankruptcy
which will stay on for 10 years but
everything else
drops off in seven years from the date
of last activity
uh and so it literally can be you you
pay an old bad bill this week
seven years from this week it goes off
it can be
but apparently sometimes the credit it's
up to the creditors to how they report
it
but apparently the creditor here is
reporting it from the date the loan was
initially made or
the date that it went into default or
something yeah rachel i just want to
encourage you hey you're walking out the
baby steps
so this isn't gonna be a factor for you
anyway number one it doesn't stain you
number two you don't need it
because you're gonna pay cash for things
so let this thing i
love the intensity and i love the
enthusiasm and the deep passion here
but uh this is not a big stain that's
gonna hold you back it's going to fall
off
and you're doing all the right things
really really proud of you keep after it
yeah
here's to ken's point um and it's not
what you were saying so i'm not
correcting you but i just want our
listening audience to hear this clearly
we don't worship at the altar of the
great fico
right your fico score is an indication
of how much money you have borrowed and
paid back
it is not an indication of wealth
let me try that again your fico score is
how much the larger your fico score the
more you've been playing kissy face with
the bank
or kissy something and so you got to
decide
you're going to play kissy with the bank
all the time you can have a big old fico
score and keep them rich
if you were going to quit borrowing
money your fico score literally does not
matter
you know what my fico score is i don't
have one it's zero
because i haven't borrowed money shame
shame shame on your dave
have you have not maximized the american
way yeah yes i have
i've got several hundred million dollars
is working out for me so you know this
is
you know this is but you're right that
you know it doesn't matter who cares
that it's on there
she's moving on yeah yeah she then i
think that's a good point but
also a good point to say she's doing
really good stuff by really watching
what's going on with it and getting the
proper things on there the proper things
off of there i did all of that too
i wanted to make sure mine was cleaned
off because uh you know after i went
through a bankruptcy it stayed on there
10 years
wow you know yeah and so i
yeah but you know what i never borrowed
money again so it really didn't come up
that's exactly right
and she did it right she got it in
writing the settlement she's doing
everything the right way
yeah she's just really cleaning things
up good for you good job rachel well
played
well played ken coleman ramsey
personality is my co-host this hour good
hour ken thank you sir good job kelly
and ben in the booth i am dave ramsey
your host we will be back
before you know it
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show
if you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit the ramsay show.com
and register we would love for you to
come to nashville and tell dave your
[Music]
story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios
it's the ramsey show where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has
taken the place of the bmw as the status
symbol of choice i'm dave ramsey your
host ken coleman ramsey personality
number one best-selling author of the
book the proximity principle
is my co-host today as we answer your
questions about career
about money about life and about life
it's a free call some say the advice is
worth what you pay for it the phone
number is triple eight
eight two five five two two five
lee's with us in cleveland ohio hi lee
how are you
hi dave um hang well how are you better
than i deserve what's up
um okay so we recently relocated from
florida to ohio
and we sold our home in florida and we
thought we'd be able to buy our house in
cleveland for cash
but with this market that's proving to
be very difficult
we have about three hundred and fifty
thousand three hundred fifty to four
hundred thousand dollars to spend
cash um but should we rent for a year
and hope the market at least comes or
should we get a small mortgage
won't neither one is in the dumb column
yes um it's just a matter of what i for
me
personally once i made the decision to
never be in debt it would be very hard
for me emotionally
to take out a mortgage again but
mathematically it wouldn't be that big a
deal for you
yeah and that's what we're thinking like
we've worked really hard we have
we're debt-free fully funded emergency
fund have about a million dollars in
investment
we're in our young young 40. um so i
guess
the million dollars is in investments is
it all in retirement
it's all retirement yeah you can't touch
it congrats and you said you're 40.
actually 42 and your everyday
millionaires way to go yeah
thanks thank you very much it's been a
long road but it's
you know i grew up with you so it was uh
it was an easy road so
well we're honored so your baby steps
millionaires then good
okay so what uh uh uh
wow so what's your household income um
with my i'm a stay-at-home mom i would
say about
200 with bonus and so how much mortgage
would you take out if you went ahead and
moved on a property now
i mean honestly we wanted to stay in a
house that's around 350.
but you said you had 350 or 400 correct
correct and that's all
like i don't want a monstrosity house
but i want help that's like updated in a
good neighborhood and those
are you know 600 650 right now and it
just
to me i don't think he's a little dumb
to spend that kind of money so
just i'm just struggling with it like in
florida i expected it i didn't
i i guess i didn't expect it in
cleveland ohio so much so
hmm so you'd take out like a 200 000
mortgage
yeah yeah probably somewhere around
there and it would take you like
three years to clear that uh probably
yeah
yeah okay well that's certainly not the
end of the world it's certainly not
going to make you go bankrupt and it's
certainly not going to keep you from
building wealth if you chose if you
choose to go that route
i don't think you're going to see the
market calm down 200 000
in 12 months right right but i i mean i
guess our thought was you know maybe we
rent and we stayed for another year and
then we have
you know 500 grand to spend or something
and then at least we're not like we've
put in bids on three homes and we've
been
outbid like the we're we're bidding ask
and then they're coming back after that
and saying we want another sixty
thousand dollars and i'm like i just i
physically can't do it like it makes me
wanna
i'm struggling well so um
and the bid on the three homes what was
the prices you bid
um we've been about 3.50
so you have found home you have found
homes that the asking price on
was a home that you would buy yes
yes but we're getting outbid like i
understand i understand
but that's different than saying i have
to jump from 350 or 400 to 600
to buy a house that's updated in
cleveland ohio
those are those and those are
incongruent conclusions
yes yes you're correct on that you're
you know the ones you're motivating on
there yeah i think i think i think i
think you're getting a little bit into
house fever drama mode
maybe maybe because you kicked up you
kicked up to 600 because you got outbid
on a 350.
yeah but keep in mind i also have two
small children and right now we're
living in a hotel so
that'll add to the drama mode that'll
add to the drama mode that'll cause
anybody to go crazy but
but um yeah i'll give i'll give you that
but i'm going to call you on your lack
of logic
okay so uh and don't forget dave that if
you pay for if you go for a 600 000
house you get in the same market
you're going to have that whole back and
forth there too yeah so
what i'm going to do is go rent but i
want an out
in the lease okay i want to be i want to
i want terms of the lease that allow me
for x number of dollars to break the
lease
and then i want you to keep bidding on
350 and 400 000 houses
until you actually get one
okay and here and what you have to do in
that process is you have to steal
yourself your emotions you have to put
your shields up
and just kind of then be surprised
when you actually get one you know what
i'm saying
instead you like got married to these
other two and it was a
deep disappointment yeah yeah
yeah so i i was i was on the golf screen
the other day
uh teeing off at the first uh hole and i
uh my
i looked down at my cell phone and uh an
offer i had made that
i fully did not expect to go through on
a property i buy real estate
i looked down and i told sharon i said
damn come we just bought that house
i said i never dreamed it was like a
surprise
because i figured in this market i was
going to get outbid i didn't figure i
was shocked
and you know and and so you kind of want
to be in that mode where you're like
pleasantly surprised that it actually
went through yes
and meaning that you're not deeply
disappointed and oh god the world's
coming to an end i gotta go buy 600 000
hours because my offer didn't go through
because you're probably going to
continue to see this now i will tell you
that the white hot market
probably apexed about 30 days ago
it's still hot still quite hot but
not as much as it was 30 days ago we're
seeing all kinds of indicators coming
back now the different markets have
different personalities
and certainly different micro markets
within markets even have different
personalities
so there might be a neighborhood or two
where it's still just going cray cray
but uh this um the the 17
offers all over asking price by 50 grand
are not happening as much today as they
were 30 45 days ago
most places nashville's hot really hot
williamson county where we live outside
of nashville really hot but it's slowed
down a little bit
a little bit not not it's not returned
to completely normal it's certainly not
bargains everywhere nothing like that
but uh the the lumber prices have come
down building is normalized
somewhat and so the frenzy
has seems to have peaked in in some
areas in most areas
so i'll tell you that sometime in the
next six months you're gonna find a
house you can buy for asking price
that you like this 350 to 400 that's why
i want you to have an
out in the lease i love that practical
advice takes all the pressure off
you've already negotiated upfront on the
lease you got the cash a bill to pay to
break the lease that really takes the
pressure off now it becomes a game yeah
that's fun
and then you then you're pleasantly
surprised when it actually
does work yeah this is the ramsey chat
[Music]
[Music]
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that even in adversity
that you have what it takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance career training
and a paycheck to help you avoid debt no
matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five well i've heard all the
excuses
the people have for putting off making a
will
i'm busy it's confusing
it's a downer it's morbid it's expensive
if i do a will i might die that's
that's my favorite yeah you're gonna die
okay
100 mortality rate in the human race
okay we've done detailed research
you're gonna die you need a will
in fact ramsey solutions research team
found that 74 of parents
don't have a will come on guys that's
not
good it's too important you need a will
to protect your family stop putting it
off
get it done start with our free will
preparation checklist
this guide helps you think through the
seven important areas like naming of
guardians
beneficiaries plus all the little things
you hadn't thought of
and once you've gone over the checklist
setting up your actual will will only
take you about 10 or 15 minutes
get the guide the free will preparation
checklist
by texting will 233
789 and you can start the morbid
uncomfortable conversation
text will 233 789 give your family peace
of mind
by getting yourself a will mine's so
stinking detail ken we have a meeting
once a year to go over all the estate
plan
with the family and the leadership team
here i call it the monty python meeting
because we all discuss dave's death and
i always go i'm feeling much better
yeah it's just a flesh wound i don't
know how you do that when you tell us
that it's kind of that has to be weird
it's creepy as crud
do you like multiple times in the media
remind everybody that you're still in
the room
other people do because it's awkward for
them so like mark floyd our cfo goes i
don't like talking about this and he
says this every year for eight years now
i don't like talking about you dying and
you dying in front of you and i'm like
well you're going to talk about me
behind my back about dying i mean come
on what is the deal
it's it's funny but uh it's it's uh it's
in in it is a matter of diligence to get
these things in place
because if you don't it costs your
family so much heartache
yeah brandon is with us brandon's in
tampa florida hey brandon how are you
hey dude how are you doing today better
than i deserve what's up
uh so i am contemplating switching jobs
and i wanted to give you a little detail
and see if you can help me to make an
informed decision
okay uh so i've worked for the same
company for 15 years
i love my company and i think what i
like best about my job is
i work from home i have really flexible
hours
so one of my kids has special needs if
he's meeting with a therapist
i can take a quick break from work and i
can meet with a therapist too
or if they have a function going on at
school i can meet them at school and i'm
home every night for dinner
and then uh i can log back into work if
i need to after they're in bed so it
kind of lets me be
super dad uh while you know my kids
still like me you know until they become
teenagers right
okay so the
uh so why are you leaving why are you
leaving nirvana
so unless i move to another city they
won't let me apply for other jobs and
they're going to lay me off
in the next three months to three years
oh okay so this is the end i kind of
nirvana's in there you got kicked out of
the garden
okay i will it's just kind of when do i
pull off the band-aid right
so i found another job that would
actually pay me more
and it would have a lot of job security
it'd be a great job
but it's probably a two to two and a
half hour commute a day
and it would be a lot of hours and i
wouldn't be home
or able to do any of this stuff with my
kids
yeah that's it you have to move is what
you have to do
yeah you would last more than three
months your heart your heart's already
telling you that's a bad idea that's
just your brain because you've got a
little bit of fear a little bit of
pressure
so that's not an option unless you move
and then you said i'm not willing to
move why you're not willing to move
uh my kids are in a great school
district love my house love my
neighborhood
i have a rental in the same street my
in-laws live on the same street
you haven't found yeah you got to keep
looking there's a good list of reasons
why we say no to that
um so i started looking for that other
job that i have
in 2018 and i was getting ready to start
that job and then it went on hold during
the pandemic
and they're trying to get me to come
back now my wife and i kind of want to
just wait until we get laid off
just so you know i'm on baby step seven
i have a fully funded emergency fund
and a large chunk of money that's in our
checking account because we're getting
rid of my car
so financially i'm in good shape where
if i got laid off it
wouldn't be the end of the world but
if and when i went to look for another
job it's very likely that i'd take a big
pay cut because the technology that i'm
working on
is very proprietary so not a lot of
other places need it
so i'd have to kind of start at the
ground what's two and a half hours away
with a raise do they have the same
technology
uh they do it's kind of a government job
so it's not just that it's two and a
half hours away it's that it's uh
a long commute with traffic i got that
part i'm asking what was the job is it
the same technology
uh it's not but they're willing to take
me because of a security clearance all
right so what is your
what would you say is your uh type of
work are you a programmer are you inside
give me a give me a job title so i can
have an idea of what we're looking at
here
being your systems engineer one thing
that's kind of funky is my current
company
because i can't apply for jobs they just
move me wherever they need me
so right now i'm not working on
technology i would apply to a job for
because i've been doing it since
february okay here's the deal
in tampa florida a great job market
good size area the systems engineer what
you have to start doing right now is
start finding
other different types of opportunities
that allow you to take your experience
and your skill set those are two
different things but i think you've got
a wonderful future
you know the idea of waiting to be laid
off that's just not how i'm
wired but because you're in baby step
seven and you've got a you've got a
a whole different perspective on things
i'm not gonna say that's not a good idea
you certainly can do it it's not
but i don't like it okay good i i don't
like it i think that that is uh
too passive and uh brandon you're in
denial
yeah you're in denial that this nirvana
is going away
it's going away and all you have said
all you have set up
are these impossible freaking scenarios
that are fatalistic all around you where
your life is not going to continue
unless you keep this job that's right
and that's a bunch of bs
this you you have a skill set that is
totally marketable
within 30 minutes of your house and you
need to go look for a new position
and that what has happened dave those
excuses those are all excuses those
scenarios become excuses for him because
he doesn't want to leave the nevada
because he doesn't want to leave them
i'm sorry but nirvana's ending yeah
they're kicking you out of the garden of
eden yeah
you don't get to live there anymore yeah
and so it's
they've told you and and the instability
of that is is
is eroding you guys it's it's eating at
you guys
and that's why you went and considered
something two and a half two and a half
hours
no yeah and by the way we just freaking
moved to orlando
oh my god and you know what you don't
have to trade off being a super dad
and being there for your kids if your
scenario changes
that again is a false choice it's a
false narrative and we do this
we create all these reasons why we
should sit tight and in this situation
he's so marketable the opportunities for
him are
endless as a systems engineer i mean
technology
that's the place to be and because he
can go just about anywhere
yeah you're going to be fine son you're
going to be fine but
you know i'm just calling you on your
stuff here you know
you you need to go look for something
that's not two and a half hours away and
if it's a little bit of a pay cut so
what
it's um you know and no i'm not going to
sit and wait
on this to come hit me in the back of
the head we know it's coming
and so um you know
go land you something and get yourself
get yourself a projected future that
feels good again
you don't have a good feeling about your
projected future nothing in your future
that you laid out sounded fun
nothing did and that's just not
accurate there's a way to put together a
life that you love here again
and uh so hey man appreciate you glad
you're at baby step
seven proud of you for doing that it
gives you some options gives you some
comfort
don't wallow in the comfort this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Applause]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt-free stage
isabella is here hi isabella how are you
hi
dave i'm doing great thank you guys for
having me today we're honored to have
you where do you live likewise i live in
los angeles california
a bit of a haul over to nashville
welcome good to have you
and how much debt have you paid off
isabella i paid off 34
473 and 82 cents
awesome how long did this take you 12
months 12 months
and your range of income during that
time it was about 56 and it ended around
60.
cool okay what kind of debt was the 34
000. the majority of
my debt was student loans okay and a
little bit of credit card
it was all student loans what do you do
for a living i'm in real estate now i
just actually passed my real estate
license
last month and so i've been doing real
estate for a few months now
in california what were you doing before
that for the 56 to 60.
before that i was actually in
international education
and i was doing that for the full year
and i was also
doing some part-time jobs as well to
supplement
my income to be really gazelle intense
and focused to pay off the student loans
good for you how old are you i'm 30 am i
going to be 31
tomorrow actually tomorrow's my birthday
well happy birthday thank you very cool
thank you okay so something happened i
mean their 20s goes away
we're sitting on 30 or so 29 or 30 and
we're looking down
and there's this nagging student loan
that won't go away what happened what
was the breakthrough
well it was actually started a few years
before that actually
i was teaching in china actually so i
was there for about four years
wow and i thought that i want i wanted
to go into government work
as a foreign service officer and so
that's why i went to go get my master's
and then i had an internship uh in hong
kong
and i decided that i really liked what i
was doing at the time but i didn't see
myself doing it long term
i would rather be focused more on the
business side
entrepreneurial side and so
i left and china and i came back to the
states
and i believe it was 2015.
and i really started to get gazelle
tense in
2019
earlier that year my mother passed away
actually
really unexpectedly and so that was kind
of the catalyst for me to really
get my affairs in order and really
focus on something that i know she would
be extremely proud
about and also for me you know i was
working in education at the time and i
was like how
should i have debt over my head when i'm
being in this field i'm
coaching students and so i i really
wanted to
clean up my backyard essentially yeah
yeah that's that's powerful
there's something about um a friend of
mine a pastor friend of mine and i were
speaking at a funeral a while back and
he made a comment i've never forgotten
he said uh
losing someone a funeral a birth either
one
are both tuning forks and it you re-tune
your life
because you we all get real
introspective when those kinds of things
happen and
the loss of your mom does that and says
okay
this life thing is short i better get it
right for sure for sure and so
later that year actually i started
financial peace university at a church
and i brought my sister along with me
and it was it was funny she made a
comment she was 21 at the time and she's
like i'm too young for this i shouldn't
be going to this
and i was just telling her actually this
is like the perfect time that you should
be learning about this
so you can grow and invest earlier and
so i dragged her along with me
and i finished the course at the end of
2019
and then in 2020 in march that's when i
got really
focused yeah and that's when i was beans
and rice rice and beans
i was doing whatever i could to get out
of debt and it was really hard because i
went through actually
you know several losses um i actually
was
going through a breakup at the time too
so there was a lot of times where it was
you know during the pandemic as well
where
everything just really seemed really
difficult a lot of stress right a lot of
stress
like loss and stuff but i always push
myself
to this that this season is not going to
last forever
and that's when i would always listen to
your podcast
i took a lot of inspiration from other
dead scream um uh people as well and
listening to your podcast when i would
drive to and from work
and that would always keep me focused
whenever i just didn't want to
work so hard or times where i just felt
like it was kind of insurmountable
uh listening to you and other people
really was something that kept me
focused on the past for sure so i want
to ask you how did this i mean
i love that story unbelievable grit so
proud of you
how did that journey that that singular
focus
on getting out of debt how did it play
into you becoming a real estate
professional and kind of scratching that
entrepreneurial itch because this i'm
assuming this was all part of the
transition getting debt free and moving
into real estate yes my
so my last position um it was a means to
an end so it was a means for me to get
out of debt once i got out of debt
um earlier this year actually i was like
i want to get my real estate license
and so uh it took me six and a half
months from when i started to when i
passed
to actually get it done so when i paid
off my debt i
was able to i went online and i fill out
the questionnaire
for dave ramsey to be here to get the
debt-free scream
and then after that i took my real
estate exam and i passed so it was just
kind of
everything just kind of happened like a
domino effect so i love this dave this
is day job the dream job
there's nothing wrong with a day job
right that gets us out of debt that
prepares us while we're getting
qualified for the dream job great job
good for you and now have you sold your
first house yet
i've sold actually four already touched
the
how does that feel it feels amazing and
i actually um
had like a mid-year review with one of
my mentors at uh
at my company and he was saying um
that you know he's kind of impressed
about how quick
i and i'm learning the ropes and i told
him this is the first time actually i've
ever had a job that i felt like matched
my personality so well yeah that's great
and uh it feels great it's like you make
your own schedule
you go in when you want to you leave
when you when you want to
and um your results are reflected on how
much effort and how hard you push
yourself yeah who'd you bring with you
i brought my sister and my father
all right they they heard me all year
long biggest cheerleaders in your life
huh non-stop talking about
your dad your dad's he's over shaking
his head he's proud of you
yeah yeah very well very good stuff
good stuff what do you tell people the
key to getting out of debt is
i tell people definitely it's
consistency
um discipline and also just a belief in
yourself because there's going to be
times
when it gets really really hard and
you're not going to really have anybody
on your side really pushing you because
everybody has their own
agenda their own things to do and so
really a firm belief and vision in
yourself and your future is what's going
to get you through those hard times
yeah way to go isabella you're a rock
star you're a hero
very very proud of you what a lot of
transition there yes a lot of change
a lot of stuff going on a lot of stress
all during a stressful time pulled it
all off yeah
you're an amazing young woman very very
well done
very well done good stuff all right
we've got a copy of the legacy journey
for you that is definitely the next
chapter in your story to
continue to change your entire legacy
now very well done and i copy the total
money makeover book you can pass that
along to someone when you're talking
about
financial peace university like you drug
your 21 year old sister there a few
years ago
so very cool stuff good stuff all right
it's
isabella from los angeles 34 000
paid off in 12 months making 56 to 60.
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream
three two one i'm debt free
[Music]
yeah this is how it's done right here
so i have a prediction for you all right
she's gonna make over 100 in real estate
business her first year
no yes for sure she's going to double
her income yeah she's going to crush it
and zoom through the baby steps because
of it just boom boom boom boom boom
ticking them off
just crushing her she got two out of the
way she's relaxed she's not afraid of
hard work
she's got a a poise yes and a way she
carries herself she's going to do
very very well in the real estate
business yeah it's going to work out
very well and but there's something
interesting there's a tie
there always has been between what you
do and what we what i do the career and
the money
right that that the the money being
right frees you up to do the career
the career being right making a lot of
money frees you up to go win with your
money that's right
they they bounce back and forth between
it's a ping pong and it works together
that's it
she did it so well it's the left right
combination and i just want to tell you
your mom is so proud i know your dad and
your sister proud but so is your mama
amen incredible fortitude proud amen
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
our scripture of the day john 14 27
peace
i leave with you my peace i give to you
i do not give to you as the world gives
do not let your hearts be troubled
and do not be afraid rosa parks
said i have learned over the years that
when one's mind is made up
this diminishes fear very true
laney is with us laney is in what in the
world did i do there
i messed up hello there's laney hey
laney welcome to the ramsey show how can
ken and i help
hey dave hi ken bear with me i have a
lot of moving pieces
um i'm an occupational therapist i work
in the hospital i also have a part-time
job and outpatient i'm on baby step two
i'm getting married in august and i'm
just
very burned out on the hospital i'm
living in asheville
my lease ends in november and the plan
was or
was for my fiance to get a job first
and i kind of go from there because my
job's more flexible
um but i got anxious found a job
got offered the job and it's going to be
an 8 000
pay raise i'm just now i'm having second
thoughts on am i cornering my fiance
into
a place or should i where is the job
and where's the job in greenville south
carolina okay so you would be moving
and your your lease is up in november
and you're getting married to win again
august august okay so had you guys
already decided on greenville south
carolina or this is where the job has
come up and now
he's got to decide or you have to decide
if that's where we want to go help me
understand
this is where the job came up so we have
not decided on a location at all
okay so if you're having second thoughts
what are his thoughts i'm saying i'm
assuming since you
mentioned him and cornering him have you
guys discussed this and what's his take
yeah um he he
isn't super decisive about it he likes
the area but
he does feel like he wishes that he
could find a job
first because i could essentially go
anywhere where his
it might be harder for him to find a job
okay so you called us which way were you
leaning at the start of this call
oh i'm really really conflicted i
i'm really worried that i am
making a rash decision like to jump on
this job because i'm so burned out at
the hospital
okay and this job would start in
september so it's kind of like
a really quick easy out for me yeah i
think you have to listen to that
uh here but i want to dive in here tell
me about the parts
that are causing you to feel burned out
and another way of asking this is what
would you remove if you had a magic wand
what would you pull away from what
you're doing right now that's sucking
your soul out
well so the biggest piece is
the salary is not what i expected
when i got the student loans that i did
okay for an occupational therapist
okay i'm working that doesn't cause you
to burn out that's not work related
that's emotion
attached to the reality that a lot of
people are facing when they get these
expensive degrees that they take loans
out and they go wait a second i thought
i was going to make more
i'm asking you do is there type is there
types of things you're doing that are
burning you out or is it just the
emotional
running to run away from this particular
hospital why
why what's sucking the life out so
it has been so many staff cuts we're
super
we've been super overworked okay so
you're overwhelmed
which is which i've i've written about
this i've got an article
on this at kencoleman.com it's one of
the five causes of what i call
build up on the heart see burn out is
the symptom if i go to the doctor
today laney with a knee with knee pain
i'm not going i've got knee pain i want
to know what's causing the pain and
and so being overwhelmed drinking from a
fire hydrant
is is what you're identifying here so
let me simplify this
if we removed all of the stuff that's
causing all this
the stress and just feeling overwhelmed
and i put you in a different place doing
occupational therapy would you be happy
in your work
yeah i think so i i am made to be an
occupational therapist
i am all right hold on on pause that
that's huge
that's what you have to realize you were
made to be an occupational therapist so
we're doing
the right thing in the wrong place we
have a little quiz at dave
well she knows that she's wanted to
leave i know but that's one of my dad
gum inside coleman
she already told you that no but but she
needs to hear that because she was gonna
take another job just as an occupational
therapist
no she was gonna take it she was gonna
she was rushing into something as
opposed to saying
i need to stay in occupational therapy
she was she was going to
stay in occupational therapy yeah so the
other job is home health
it's not occupational therapy it's still
it's an occupational therapist
i thought you were staying you're
staying in the career but i thought i
heard her say it was a little bit
different than what she's doing now
did i misunderstand that let me back up
a second on something that's bothering
me in this whole thing
when are you getting married again
august
okay this is this is july
so when is it your fiance is going to go
get a freaking job
my thoughts exactly yeah
i think he needs to get off painter get
off the ladder here
yeah but you should not take the job in
greenville i don't think that's good for
the
relationship no i think but i think he's
got about 30 days
or no no whining like by the time you
get married he should have his job lined
up in the city
and then you go over there and get you
an occupational therapy job in that city
and you're still going to be in there by
september yes
and the point but him sitting around on
his butt till christmas not figuring
this out is not one of the options on
the table
right you could tell him i said that
or are you waiting on him like why do
you have to why does he have to go
you're not forcing him he does need to
get his button gear
but here's the point i'm trying to make
laney dave's having fun with me i get it
here's the point
you're not burned out from being an
occupational therapist
you're just burned out in the current
environment don't mistake that that's
all
stay with occupational therapy yeah
you're doing the right thing but
get out of that environment i agree and
i'm i'm with you on this lanny i think
you can land that pretty easily
and you just have to be selective about
the environment wherever he wants but
he loses his option on cities
if he doesn't take the option by the
wedding
okay do you think i'd give him 30 days
he gets to
he gets until then to choose cities and
choose his little career
thing otherwise he'd be following you
yeah
yeah and i don't want that i i want him
to grow in his career i do too but that
means he has to actually go do it
he has to get on the ladder before he
can climb
yeah what's he do what's his what's his
field
he's a supervisor in commercial
landscaping
well you can do that anywhere yeah i've
never heard of a supervisor in
landscaping deciding which city he wants
to go to i mean you guys collectively
say that this is where we want to live
we he can go do that anywhere as well
and you can go do occupational therapy
anywhere so
let's let's have a meeting tomorrow
night decide where we want to live
and then let's go get a couple jobs
there before the wedding yeah and
then you can quit your job and you'll be
out of that hospital by september
and you go to occupational therapy and
he goes dude goes and does commercial
landscaping
i mean any major metro area has got
commercial landscaping believe me
anybody's got office buildings and
apartments and so forth that's just
that's the deal
um so i mean there's 73 000 of them
within a two mile radius of this place
they're over here every day bothering us
so um
i know that you know it's just possible
right i mean can you yeah they want to
get this job right
this this building yeah there's a lot of
landscaping to do around here
yeah so you're telling me you're not a
fan of the leaf blower right outside of
the conference rooms
is that what i'm hearing i don't know it
was like a thing at the old office every
time we would start a meeting
some guy would cope out with a leaf
blower about the time we're in the room
full of stuff
right in the middle of the meeting so
yeah the great news is you can land
both of these jobs anywhere you guys
want to do laney this is about you all
getting aligned on your timing
and your motivation and ambition and
both of you being on the same page
you're more driven to get out of that
hospital and he's not driven enough
i'm kicking him in the butt in this call
because he's leaving you on hold
and you on hold is driving you bananas
and you're screaming burn out burn out
burnout yeah
and there's really no burnout because
you're gone by september
you can survive until september i
promise yeah
so you got this kid congratulations on
your marriage it's gonna be awesome
you're gonna have a great new city
picked out by the end of the week
awesome it's gonna be incredible ken
good job thank you for having me
fun stuff good job in the booth guys i'm
dave ramsey your host we'll be back with
you before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace
and that's to walk daily with the prince
of peace christ jesus
[Music]
hey guys this is james senior producer
for the ramsay show
did you know over 18 million people
listened to the ramsay show every week
and a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country
to find a station near you head to
[Music]
thermsyshow.com
you